apparently Marshon Lynch didn't have the
best relationship with Russell Wilson
which isn't that surprising but he
revealed a story just to show how weird
their relationship really is in an
interview with Shannon sharp on Club
Shay Marshon said that he would take
Russ as a quarterback but that's it they
never had that many off field
interactions and here's the part that's
really weird when Marshon would try to
contact Russ after games Russ called him
back on a blocked number and gave not so
welcoming responses why wouldn't Russ
have maron's number saved Marshon also
claimed to have the entire Seahawks
roster over at his place but when
Shannon asked if that also included
Russell Maron simply gave him a blank
face that should tell you all you need
to know about their relationship but it
goes to show that not everything goes so
smoothly behind the scenes for Super
Bowl winning teams